[拍手]
はぁ
皆さんはじめまして
私はドキュメンタリー映画の監督を生業としているし良い香りと申します
私はこれまで8作品の映画を監督したんですけれども
うち3作が日本の伝統技術を継承する職人された状態映画を打つおりました
まずは人生のターニングポイントとなったデビュー作
映画をめぐるの予告編をご覧下さい
町外れの工房で素敵なものに出会いました
[音楽]
me
仕事をやってて疲れたなんてことはないですよ
んとっ
楽しいですね
いや自分ものを作ることが正しい
うん
ん
[音楽]
ほんとね30節ちーさんのです
当然たいっ
[音楽]
n
はいありがとうございます
自画自賛になりますがこの作品
すごくいいですん
2006年の関西なんですけれども
インド更紗から伝わったごはん染め
型染めの最後の技法と呼ばれているものですがこれを今に伝える職人
ふじもとよしかげさんの職人という生き方というものを追った作品になります
ちなみにこのもごはん爪と言われる技術は今日本でたった2人しか
継承者がいないとされています
次に
職人を負ったとキュメンタリーガー
1兄のしようっていう作品を撮りました
これは石川県の能登半島の先端の涼しというところでこれまで一度も途切れず作られ
続けてきた
揚げ浜場を手掛ける職人さんを追った作品です
[音楽]
小づくりを通して
自然とともにある暮らしぶりというテーマに行き着きました
一番最近のドキュメンタリー映画は1本の系譜という作品です
これはやはり2位は同じく石川県の能登半島ですが
今度は酒造りその職人
当時さんの技と思いの継承を描いた作品です
このように
日本の伝統技術を伝える職人さんをドキュメンタリー映画で撮った監督なんて言うと
どこか社会派ななんか切れ者なイメージを抱かれるかもしれませんが実は私結構残念な
パイプで
大学を卒業してすぐの就職試験では前者が落ちまして
で
専門の技術を身につけようと思って通い始めた映画学校の監督の権利を得る
プレゼンテーションでも美琴落ちまして
本当にダメダメなんですねでそんな中
ネット上で見つけた1枚の
着物
その美しさに
見とれて
虜になってしまいました
これを染めたのが
先ほどの巡るという速品の
藤本良和さんです
このもごはん爪というのは
そのあまりの手間からん
みんなが手放した技術です
けれども藤本さんはこれが楽しくて仕方がないといってどんどん込み入った柄を
掘り起こして
宇宙になってそれを上げています
生産性という側面を考えると時代に逆行していると言われるかもしれませんがそんな
ことお構いなして
小野作りにまっすぐといっくん
職人という生き方に私は救われました
この藤本さんとの出会いがきっかけで私は映画監督の人生を始めることになったんです
カメラがあれば
今まで出会ったことのない世界の人たちと出会える
今までものすごく狭い世界で生きてきた私にとってそれはとても大きなことで
呼吸をするようにドキュメンタリー映画が必要になりました
しかしながら
この業界に入るまで私はドキュメンタリー映画というもの映画館で見た事がありません
でした
おそらく
全国的に見てもドキュメンタリー映画を映画館でご覧になった方っていうのはわりと
少ないのかなと思います
なおかつそのドキュメンタリーで扱われている物や人に会いに行くとかしたことがある
人というのは本当に限られているのかなと思います
でも
ドキュメンタリー映画の最大の強みというのは
映像の中で写し込まれた
もの一
環境それらがすべて実在するということです
映画をご覧になった人が後日その人に会いに行くことも可能なんです
それって現実社会を変えていくことだと思います
とてもすごいことだと感じました
3振るうをご覧になったお客様方が
あの着物を買いたいというおっしゃって
その数があまりにも多かったので
20名を超す
まあお客さん達を集めてですね
藤本さん工房に遊びに行かせていただいてその場でかわしていただいたりオーダー
メイドさせて頂いたりしたんですけれども
藤本さんはこれまで
新規顧客の開拓というと
エバーたの
百貨店で
最初するときとかそれぐらいの
着替えしかなかったんですけれども
映画という切り口を得て人生が変わったとおっしゃってくださいました
自分をつくってくれた職人さんに
ラブレターのつもりで作った映画がこうして
少しでも役に立てて
恩返しができたのかなととても嬉しかったです
この一連の経験から
私は13年間ドキュメンタリー映画を作り続けてきました
そしてその中で
夢が出来ました
それは
正しいと信じる者を軽やかに述べて現実社会を変えていくということです
これはドキュメンタリー映画に対する私の夢であり今もその夢を
描いてん
活動しています
第二のターニングポイントとなったのは一握りのショーでした
現在皆さんも
ご存知の通り食卓塩という
工業生産される大量に生産するすることができる
性が日本には存在します
にもかかわらず
過酷な労働を擁する揚げ浜子様というものにこだわり続けて作り続けてる人と出会って
しまいました
その過酷さタリア
元自衛隊の隊員だった方がその訓練よりも
ツイートもらったことで
炎天下の作業は雨がいったん振ると一からやり直し
釜谷の温度はセ氏60度を込めていていったん火をくべると
一昼夜でくれません
そんな過酷な労働を経て
それでも種を作りたい
なぜ種を作りたいのか
そうすると
体に良くて美味しいしを作りたいんだとおっしゃいました
体に良くて美味しいしを作りたいという気持ち
これは絶対に正しいことだと思います
絶対に正しいことをしようとしている人が目の前にいるばいい
その想いを貫ける社会を作るために協力すべきだと思いました
どんなに正しくても
消滅していく文化を山ほどあると思います
自分のことではないと思い込んで
視界に入りながら何もしないということで消えていた文化も山ほどあると思います
気付いているのに何もしないということは消滅へ片足ていることと同じことだと私は
感じます
気づいた人がそれをする責任があるこれはマザーテレサの言葉です
塩は命の源です
綺麗な妙綺麗なものに保つこと
これは魚介類の問題以前に明日の命に直結する指標を確保するためにとても大事なこと
です
しかし
元の仕事で会う前に私は一度も仕様のことなんて
あえてなんてと言いますが考えたことがありませんでした
生まれてから1日も欠かさず食べてきたのにです
そこで私は気づきました
人は当たり前すぎることが築けない
元の方々が過酷な労働を必要とするにも関わらず
循環型の集を作る
それは自然と共に暮らすという
わきまえを持っているということではないかと思います
人間は自然界に依存しなくては生きてはいけない
こんな当たり前のメッセージを当たり前だからこそ大きな声で走っていかなければいけ
ないんだと思います
その上で
どう生きていくか何を選択していくかがようやく考えられ始めるのではないでしょうか
こんなこともありました上映会とともに仕様の初回をしました
そこに参加した子が家に変えと米を炊いて
祥瑞を握ったというんです
その後は
今まで植民無頓着で
そんなことをしたの初めてだったそうです
また
もっと低学年の子供たちと一緒に1周の食べ比べのワークショップをしたとき
揚げ浜塩お代わりしたくて
私の周りに子供たちが群がったこともあります
子どもたちの磨くはとても敏感です
子どもたちの食の未来が変わるということは社会で大事とされる
基準が変わるということ
だからこそコガモの家に
本物の味を味わえる機会をつくってあげたいと思います
繰り返しますが
今こうして私がそれらしく話していたり映画なんていう方法で大げさに伝えていること
は
実は
当たり前のことだと思います
当たり前に大事なこと
最近では
映画監督という仕事以外にも講演活動とか
イベントツアーの企画執筆などをやって
手垢がついたような
言葉でも考え方でも大事だと思うことにアクセントをつけて発信し続けています
これは何も特別なことではありません
なぜなら今 sns というものが発見して
1個人がメディアになれるからです
ですからどうぞ皆さんも
自分がいいと信じられるものを軽やかに述べていってください
きっとその活動が日本の未来の
殻となっている
世界に現場していくと思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]